hello everybody please take your seats
and settle down
today we shift from our lesson on why
buying printer ink is the world's
biggest waste of money to my latest
finding buy an expensive fitness tracker
just isn't worth it
I've tested so many smart watches and
fitness bands up and down my arms but
the proof finally arrived with the
jawbone up 3 which costs a hundred and
eighty dollars I've been testing it for
the last week and it simply isn't worth
your money while juglans app and
software platform are still the best in
this space it's hardware just isn't
that's why fitness bands like these
aren't long for this world more powerful
smartwatches like the Apple watch do so
much more and work with Jawbone's own
software platform and if you're not
ready to make the SmartWatch commitment
look at the jawbone up - which costs
just $100 the biggest difference between
the up 3 and the up 2 is that the 3 is
slightly thicker it has these
bioimpedance sensors which can measure
heart rate body temperature and other
biometrics the key word there is kin
right now it doesn't actually give you a
live reading of your heart rate like the
Apple watch and the Fitbit charge HR do
instead it only calculates your resting
heart rate when you're sleeping yeah
thanks jaw bone I know I didn't sleep
well because this guy was up all night
the problem is I don't really buy all
this sleep tracking mumbo-jumbo
and if I did the up - also has sleep
tracking features I'll be it not as
detailed both also have this frustrating
clasp which is hard to put on and either
one has a screen like competing products
but if there's a benefit to that it's
that the battery lasts a solid week I
think you're starting to see now why the
extra $80 so the deluxe up doesn't make
much sense especially when the real
value is in Jawbone's app which works
with both of them but oh that app this
is where jawbone really shines and even
beats Apple and Fitbit the app displays
basic information about your steps and
sleep in very pretty charts but what
jawbone does with that information makes
all the difference
smartcoach feature monitors your
activity and makes useful suggestions
another thing I love the up 2 and up 3
automatically know when I've started
working out the best part about jawbone
is obviously its software and soon you
won't even need jobless hardware to get
it's smart intelligence job one already
works with Apple's health app and soon
it will release an Apple watch app
obviously that confuses things quite a
bit
but here's what I want you to write down
and highlight if all you want is basic
fitness tracking in a band with no
screen and a week of battery life go
with the tracker that costs $100 or less
the up two is a fine choice but if you
want to screen more advanced sensors and
lots of fitness and other functionality
go for a SmartWatch like the Apple watch
or wait for some of the other options to
get better that's all for today tomorrow
we'll tackle wireless plans scam or huge
scam